[Musique]
- qui sait en philippe oui ça va non non
je suis chez moi je vais sortir et
j'étais sûr j'étais surtout choqué votre
bagnole maintenant je vais sortir tuer
ou belle et de ville je suis reprise au
député tu sais quoi à la prison d'ain
tarascon la présidente à ce corps est
hyper peur parce que j'ai dit non non
non non mais je te raconterai non ça va
c'est à toi qu'il faut demander ça
qu'est ce tu fais beaucoup de sport je
m'inclus musclé que moi un jeu mais tu
vas pouvoir faire ce robot avec toi tu
vas pouvoir faire des plans des gros
noms mais si on bosse ensemble on a le
boulot pour toi on fait une émission sur
l'a6 qui s'appelle flashbacks et on a
besoin d'un ont fait des blind test on a
besoin dit ok donc été engagée dès que
tu sors le lendemain tu pries dis-moi
temps d'alain bernard est la fille d'un
chef il ya un an la drogue on plaisante
sur me raconter et écoutez là non il ya
de quoi quand même non sinon la prison
serait vide
ce n'est pas donc en présence il est à
noter
qu'est ce qui laisse emmener en prison
par contre les crs bientôt y être
pédophile et oui ça au fait des mois d
ophélie il n'a pas trop surveillants à
voile et alors elle sent comment était
passé du [__] quand même
bah j'ai failli au début tu vois pas
j'étais un petit peu vers clé et puis
non finalement ce peintre qui vit des
becs sur pattes pour pas très beau sur
pas beau à tomber par terre alors y en a
il y en a aucun qui t'a pris de force
c'est pour ça que ça fait une amie ce
qu'il est important et plus tu sous la
porte
cet accord se respecte un peu mais
échangent et tu vas insulté nouvellement
sympa mais bon maintenant je fais des
émissions qu'on ne voit pas c'est drôle
que tu m'appelles maintenant on va
écouter écouter les portois garder pour
toi comment c'est cool aussi l'attraper
avec la avec la génération des portables
vous c'est pas la seule victime en
parler puisque dès que tu sors n'hésite
pas à me rappeler dès que tu sens que tu
viennes 90 là 10h01
peut-être un peu à l'écart
[Musique]
dans ma caisse jetables ou
comment
[Musique]
coutu
quand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
la poulie l'alliance du colis débat là
d'être en face non non suite
ça
[Musique]
vétérans
[Applaudissements]
ça va mais il faut trouver un aussi bon
jovi est possible ou non mais ça va mal
tout sexe voilà des buttes chaumont à
droite et sa gauche par ses toiles
fameux picoler il part avec moscou et
légendes où je crois ce qu'on une
aujourd'hui terrain des commandes
vocales bondissant mieux au fond mon
éditeur téléphoniques et qu'en même
temps en moins d'un mois
kulesza rosa ambrose et ça c'est pas
trop de questions je vois rouge
un petit coup de rouge enfin je sais pas
moi vous avez dû sidi bou lawal nous
l'avouer nous on faisait tout en
rejoignant ouazzani
je suis content de te voir raconte moi
un peu si c'est le côté conte de fées
ouais on se retrouve à feu des livres
policiers puis un jour sur le téléphone
de françoise hardy
la victoire à ses débuts du coup de
fouet a été bon
on y raconte les histoires qu'on a envie
de faire
c'est là qu'il faut d'humour
les chiffres qu'on annonçait tout à
l'heure oui j'ai fait des polars
d'ailleurs qui se passe dans le qui se
passe dans le 19e moi je suis comme chez
ce terme ça je vais essayer de raconter
toute la vie en deux blocs d'immeubles
et j'entraîne pour manger un truc ou un
petit truc je crois que j'ai des merguez
on va faire simple dont l'adversaire
bernis et se sont mariés juste après
c'est ça qui est un petit peu enfin
cesser le côté humoristique jédir de la
chose c'est que l par deux chiffres la
marion après peut-être leur plus gros
succès
aujourd'hui j'en avais eu soudain si
j'avais su ouais bah c'est un petit clin
d'oeil à l'aiment bien en ce moment ça
m'a fait plutôt sourire samuel dumoulin
est évident qu'ils s'en aller comme ça
tire ça est en soi le livre s'est fait
assez facilement doucement cela posé
trop de problèmes
ils me tueraient depuis tellement de
temps que moi j'ai juste eu à recopier
la famille alors raconte c'est très bien
alors cette famille par ordre
d'apparition du match et le père la mère
alors le père je suis au grenier
antilles est allé aux appareils non né à
tarbes
il a déjà commencé et déjà un mulâtre
comme au début il était bien un black
moi j'ai eu deux timbres et la maman
marion diotte tout six moulins enfin
donc ces deux là sont rencontrés
relativement tardivement puisque enfin
pas tardivement mon père il a rencontré
ma mère il avait 10 ans et ma mère en
avait déjà vais déjà voir ce que je
raconte dans le livre degré qui fait
rouler sa bourde ou de sa future famille
tombe amoureuse alors il a mis un peu de
temps avant de l'épouser elle est tombée
vol et là il a épousé ma mère le jour de
ses 21 ans et ma mère avait déjà eu huit
enfants et après vous
j'étais quatre enfants dans mois donc on
est à huit plus simple puisque j'ai une
petite soeur qui a disparu très tôt donc
si france les 13 13 dans une maison je
prends mon compte comme la pièce la
maison à qui l'on a vécu puisque les
chaudronniers ça veut dire quoi oui
ouais enfin chaudronnier c'est le bon ça
tape serait tall et il lui fabriquer
plutôt des avions militaires français
d'accord c'était un nouveau les
qualifiés ils travaillent et la france
c'est pour ça qu'il ya certaines de ses
aventures qui se rattachent à ça puisque
ce que j'avais une mère tellement
amoureuse de le faire que c'était son
héros alors le racontait comme jeu comme
sur le décrit dans le film pour lui pour
elle il a il a sauvé la france il a
fabriqué la caravelle il a initié marcel
cerdan et là on a connu edith piaf on
affronte manchester ait même système qui
s'ébroue père qui pêchait mon père il a
fait de travailler à la base de mes
recettes kabila travail honnêtement
blanc effectivement la maison c'était
lui qui avait fait la base le tunnel
sous le mont blanc et ben voila moi tout
seul il a fait tout ça merci c'est
gentil
il a fait tout ça donc voilà c'est ça
les mamans c'est les mamans qui font les
hérauts au petit garçon donc moi j'avais
10 ans je ne vais quand même pas mettre
en question ce que disait ma mère
et puis donc de ce que je raconte dans
le livre fait toujours un petit les
éléments fondateurs là qui déclenche on
avait une petite maison la compères
avaient réquisitionné la maison histoire
de se détendre et parce qu'ils voulaient
pas aller au centre d'apprentissage pour
bon donc qui va on il a réquisitionné
une maison comme on dit on maquille à
l'époque on risque ici on squatte étant
réquisitionnés et
un matin je les ai vus dans la dans la
cuisine il avait une cicatrice en comme
ça dans l'eau d'un peuple à tout un
peuple attend l'ouverture un poumon
parce que c'était brûlé pour moi
vraiment une ré plein de choses des gens
et je vois ça je regarde c'est une
griffes de tigre os
à partir de là j'ai pu suivre nous
avancer rapidement très rapidement
qu'ils ont fait l'essentiel
moi je leur restitue à mes parents tout
ce qu'ils m'ont donné vraiment d'avoir
des conditions extraordinaires par mètre
carré par mètre carré mais en amour en
amour ça a débordé par tous l'âge et les
fouaces est inversement proportionnel il
paraît qu'ils aient des relations même
la thématique de gens tout cas chez moi
si ces mètres carrés amour c'est
largement inversement proportionnel ça
c'est sûr ouais c'est ce qui déborde la
maison elles ont débordé quoi était à
l'école j'allais à l'école j'avais
brescia vais aller à l'école parce qu'il
paraît que c'est une contrainte et que
l'on peut pas échapper quand on est
enfant et c'était vraiment s'étendre là
c'est à dire moi j'allais à l'école
enfin j'me des petites affaires ont
refusé mais petit change tout mais
combinés tuques la mer voilà mais qui
compterait un aspect petits trafics
j'avais des médailles du travail bref je
faisais mes petites affaires et j'avais
surtout deux petites soeurs
cette année des petites soeurs sable
dans les bacs bleus tencer deux petites
soeurs qui avaient un an et deux ans de
moins que moi et puis je vais les
emmener à l'école en fresque ça les
familles nombreuses aussi c'est qu'on
élève ceux qui suivent moi j'ai trouvé
aussi autant à mes parents mes frères et
soeurs ça c'est très important
mes petites soeurs elle était collante
comme toutes les petites soeurs on peut
imaginer mois pour m'en débarrasser je
racontais des histoires sont racontées
sur le chemin de l'école des dix mois et
puis un jour elles ont voulu une
histoire je leur avais déjà raconté
alors je racontais une nouvelle à chaque
fois une enseigne qui leur avaient pas
je sais pas quoi chez moi je me rappelle
plus bon c'est sûr accompagné soir nous
on va voir moment le dicton place par ci
par là et puis un maudit bon gars écoute
si je te rappelle pas des histoires tac
à les écrire
ouais et c'est de là que à partir de ce
moment là je me suis plus contenté de
raconter les histoires je les ai écrites
ah ouais ça pendant ces jeunes qui
habitent là vers les 10 ou huawei je
monte dans mon cerisier oui bon mais
c'est ce que j'appelais écrire
j'aimerais bien retrouver des traces de
sa mère de tête
je vais mettre quelques mots pour me
rappeler un peu de la trame pour sa
petite soeur soient satisfaites voilà
comme on dit en scène ses soeurs à
l'état j'en fais quoi maintenant
bientôt ça se travaille quand même nom
le style moi je crois qu'en fin août au
travail parce que j'ai fait quand même
trois quatre livres même quatre livres
avant pour travailler le style et
surtout ce vraiment encore là l'origine
et chez mes parents on voit le père
chaudronnier slovaquie on travaille à la
table à dessin regler faut pas que ça
bouge d'un millimètre bien la mère de
famille le fer à repasser d'un côté
accusé un peu de temps même temps tu
mélange les deux temps le foisonnement
et la rigueur le travail bien fait le
souci du travail bien fait et de l'autre
côté
l'imagination et puis le foisonnement
c'est à dire que ma mère a commencé une
histoire alors prenez vous a parlé du
tonton a parlé du cousin un relief avait
soulevé la casserole c'est un roman du
19e alors bon moi c'est un peu notre âge
écrit j'essaie d'écrire comme une mère
de famille nombreuse plus un
chaudronnier dernière sa planche à
dessin en mélange des deux ça fait
quelque chose comme ça comment ça se
passe l'appliquent à lui sur saint aubin
saint valentin l'avantagé à ga ga fana
dans le serveur s'appelle pascal qu'il
m'appellera
il trouve que des analogies et donc
régulièrement il suit parce que votre
jour le parisien fait une page de
phénomènes comme ça on doute de deux
copains là des marchands de journaux
j'ai acheté mes journaux tous les matins
tu as suivi mais même les polars ils ont
même mis le champ de personnes dont
beaucoup s'étaient cessé de coco des
villages ça cela dresse aussi le petit
clin d'oeil mais chacun sait ce qu'il en
est à sa 11e de nulle part c'est avec
les filles savaient c'est mieux foot ça
ne change rien des signes on parle
gentil et puis disons que les filles ne
viennent pas d'arriver ouais mais bon ça
c'est je sais qui tu ressembles julien
perd lui aussi la une ce sens mais sa
mère c'est l'inversé c'est lui c'est
l'inversé les cartes auront comme moi
est faux car on va nabeul à peu près
même de vote dilution ouais mais je
chanterai pas qu'est ce qui va se passer
là bas ce qui va se passer là c'est
après avoir absorbé tout ce qui est le
côté c'est-à-dire il ya une suite j'ai
mes parents j'ai une histoire que je
veux écrire qui est le plus beau le plus
bel été je pense un des plus beaux étés
la famille et mon plus bel été à moi
j'ai alger en 1960 160 j'avais 12 ans
mon père travaillait souvent à levier
pour réparer des avions va et il nous a
payé les vacances du ciel sont dus
économiser du tout et on s'est retrouvés
alger la famille une partie de la
famille et moi au bout de trois jours je
me suis retrouvé à vendre des bengals et
dans l'est
tout autour d'alger surtout à fort de
l'eau et c'est un livre dont je pense
qui s'appellera les bengalis de fordo et
moi qui serai ces deux mois sans manger
voilà mais non merci non et vous êtes de
nouveau du sud algérie ou d'en parler de
la gérer la règle algérie
dites moi que vous connaissez fort de
l'eau ça me ferait plaisir
ah ouais sers-toi a gelé un peu ça n'a
jamais été éclairés éclairé comme ça
secousses là c'est lui la star
là toutes les couleurs la tête toutes
les couleurs alors
et je mange du couscous comme j'ai mangé
mon premier et mon premier moi je les
mange et à fort de l'eau parce que tout
le monde croit qu'on connaissait qu'on
connaît le couscous depuis toujours non
années 60 c'est rien du tout l'un du
tout il est arrivé dans les valises
il est arrivé dans les valises je trouve
que paris a changé depuis les pieds
noirs sont arrivés parce qu'ils ont
apporté une couleur à paris qui avait
pas du tout avant quand on regarde le
paris des années 50 ou 60
il s'appelle tiens on s'aperçoit que
pour apporter quelque chose
et puis il ya d'autres choses moi je
vais sur le canal très régulièrement et
quand je vois les gars faire rouler les
boules
ouais j'y suis moi aussi fou que les
bouteilles étaient vite hors fonds j'en
étais parti pour un petit livre léger 1
par les 2 1 d'une wii parce que mamour
le ce bouquin par le parlement
parle de tout ça c'est à dire que même
une mère 4 est alarmant c est lundi 13
ans avant mais moi des fois je me dis
elle avait cadré sa mère qu'elle rêve
parce que c'est long et induites
maintenant c'est ce que ça veut dire
d'avoir 1 2 3 et pays a reçu bon c'est à
dire qu'on va devoir leur donner tout à
chacun sait ce qu'on veut tous et sont
moins on veut tous pour son monde ne
vaut pas qu'il est alors qu'est ce
qu'elle voulait faire et elle a sa
réponse était en avoir d'autres alors
est ce que j'avais peut-être une maman
que des fuites en avant
ouais peut-être même aujourd'hui je
n'arrive pas à me dire peut-être que
maman à laver c'est bien à prévoir quand
je dis maman ma mère mouvement avait
peut-être des rêves qu'elle a même
jamais brut et ou kala peut-être et puis
peut-être temps en temps quand elle se
sait dans la cuisinière qui prenait son
café que toute la maison était vide
tu avais plus personne mais un môme plus
c'est à songer à ça
[Musique]
ça va et toi la tienne à thiennes fait
l'émission ne vois plus je vois c'est
pour ça à mon avis c'est pour ça qu'elle
peut marcher parce qu'on me voit plus
j'imagine que ça peut marcher si ça peut
aider
oui parfois c'est quoi ton parfum sont
bons cacharel pour hommes
kesha pour moi samantha la pêche
wa rouiba lui a il est en pleine forme
doit avoir 10 ans on dépasse bientôt
d'une tête et puis savoir ça se passe
bien l'école ça se passe bien au
conservatoire de conservatoire où il
apprend quoi bien nous peut-être nous
sommes fais là il est en quatrième année
de solfège et une halle passeront leur
deuxième année de là nous mettre aussi
doué que son grand-père il son père
aucune idée je lis mon football pour
changer de sport et comment il s'appelle
alors à l'école lucien ginsburg du sien
bur melvin écrits du film gainsbourg
gainsbourg les mômes à l'école ils
savent que c'est le fils de django
c'est chiant c'est chiant parce que sans
arrêt c'est y rentre de l'école en
pleurs parce qu'on lui a dit que j'étais
une came que ton père était à came que
son père c'est un sale con parce qu'il a
brûlé un billet de 500 balles donc lui
sa sale con il est jugé toujours à
travers nous en bientôt se faire traiter
de joie j'imagine donc ça touche
vraiment ce que je vois moi moi quand
c'est moi je lui explique que bon je
vais aller à l'école que je vais aller
voir les parents et tout ça mais avant
il casser la gueule qu'on me disait quoi
que ce soit sur nous maintenant je suis
dit tu essayes de passer au dessus tout
ça puis il a du mal
une fois et comme ça a pu piquer qui lui
a dit ça il m'a dit je vais pas casser
la gueule j'ai dit quand ils font
atteint à hauteur maintenant tu leur
casse la gueule et de ma part mais j'ai
demandé à rencontrer les parents les
parents veulent pas j'imagine que c'est
pas des mots comme ça le monde n'a pas
inventé que certains brûlés à 1500 même
pas mais dès que ça touche son père
mais bon les peuples
oui il faut rien williams ou sans rien
ils arrivent à avoir 16 ou quatorze mois
yann ouais c'est un fainéant génial quoi
ça finit en tout court il est génial au
plein d'autres choses
nos formateurs bâtiment
d'une bride et noël
il sait qu'ils étaient en berne ont bien
sûr atteint comptage est partie avec
cinq angles à peine sourire avec son
père et à chaque fois qu'il a nommé des
ballons tu vois que ça du pop et amuse
bouche et pas de l'oie de chez teal pour
les chaussures car il laisse partir le
maliciel dit ce peuple a pour lui son
père il est magique
il peut le voir mais n'ont pu le voir
non pas relus par bah on parle de lui au
présent donc c'est pas vraiment bien au
bout de quatre ans choix
ça n'a toujours pas signé
autre et
on est tous les deux chez un thérapeute
je sais pas si ça va marcher mais on y
sert faut pas mourir qu'on veut pas trop
tu sais que c'est à cause de serge que
j'ai fait des enfants c'est seul truc
bien que sur lequel j'étais tombé quand
il est parti il te mens 2 10 m
ce qu'ils pensaient de gainsbourg et toi
tu as dis juste une chose
serge la façon dont il parlait de 106
mètres donne envie d'avoir des enfants
et justement j'en ai fait ouais je
pensais pas faire des enfants
mais à partir du moment où gainsbourg
effet des enfants je me suis moi aussi
j'en avais déjà fait avant moi c'est ma
façon c'est une des premières dignité a
vu que j'avais fait c'était j'avais dit
c'est d'ailleurs celui du mec tout ce
que tu t'en vois tu avais pas peur que
le petit lulu c'est un peu mongolo
hessels avait choqué c'est que j'étais
arrivé bien placé pour le savoir
si l'amendé comme pendant la grossesse
l'enfant risque et une fois que c'est
dans le tiroir dire que l'amerrissage
il ya problème ça a été ma chance vous
écouter des chansons moi au départ ça a
été très difficile et surtout quand ils
passent à la télé et lui m'a dit
maintenant c'est la seule façon dont tu
peux avoir mon père c'est la télé une
portance et les cassettes
c'est tous les jours n'est besoin comme
moi vous écoutez quoi il aime bien les
vieilles chansons
ouais deux premières chansons oui
effectivement il aimait beaucoup aux
enfants de la chance mais ça tout petit
quand il avait deux ans et demi sa
chanson préférée au réveil ses deux
enfants de la chance
bon et puis là il aime bien une chanson
comme une bible et lituanie ciel du
vivant et il ya une chanson qu'il
l'avait marqué c'était d'octobre je suis
docteur jekyll
y avait il à vue j'ai pas à la télé son
père était dans un fauteuil hop le
fauteuil tone hop il y aller il a
disparu heures il a trouvé ça génial
c'était magique
il aime bien toute cette époque il adore
me posner des lilas et puis il a une
oreille presque parfaite donc et il
entend trois notes il sait que son père
tout de suite mais je sais pas ce qui
fera j'espère qu'il fera pas la même
chose que serge qu'aucun risque d'être
difficile pour lui comme bon déjà c'est
pas facile petit note elle subit ce nom
mais bon aussi après fossiles doit être
plus doué que son père si les pneus sont
ramassés en plein la gueule parce que je
ne conçois pas moi ça ne m'enchante pas
vraiment mais enfin bref
quel âge comptes a rencontré serge
disney
non ça rajeunit ça rajeunit personne
on a effectivement tu peux me passer une
plainte
ouais tiens
la tuer mais d'autres mecs depuis à ton
avis non
je pense que c'est difficile quoi et je
suis pas me mettre trop comment oui j'y
suis déjà une sorte de cour suit pas une
sainte
mais bon je peux être au courant quoi tu
c'était à refaire exactement la même
chose
tu sors un peu
pas beaucoup
costard je te rases dix minutes et samos
le soir là il
mel gibson douala fait dégager attaque
pour que je m'assoie côté demi je les ai
dire ça à temps il est venu s'asseoir à
côté de noah fait sentir action la tête
tu vois moi je suis parti j'ai détourné
et grimper sur l'olympe devant ne pas
lui demander monsieur excusez moi mais
c'était tellement lourde avec lourd
parfois les américains n'étaient pas
bons il vaut mieux les des fatwas garder
l'image des gens comme tout les voit
dans les films présentés valeur ajoutée
d'abord ne pensais pas qu'il était si
petit on sceptiques moi toi
vous savez qui c'est passé vite j'ai
tout par mel gibson à canon autant il
était bien dakar c'est tout parce
qu'après gilles arriver à être trop dans
l'armé fatale fait beaucoup rire lui
ça mais bon bref
ça va changer trop tu trouve toi non
plus c'est dommage qu'on ne voit pas
c'est ma quand même vu leur moi je sais
ça va bonsoir je te présente l'homme
caméra jours ardisson coup quitté sept
jours sans télé 7 jours qu'est ce qu'on
fait en tournant c'est toi on boit un
coup bon bah assieds toi là tiens rien
mais voilà elle va un peu de sancerre
ouais allez c'est parti
je sais qu'avec l'hiver tu pourrais
mettre des chaussettes
c'est l'époque qu'est ce que tu veux
attend il faut en mettre
tu viens chez adam avec nous là c'est
quoi la dans une boîte de partouzes pour
moi j'aime beaucoup je me lève
succursales et provocateur il habite au
fin fond du 16e dans des flaques d'enfer
avec des feux de cheminée et veulent pas
venir dans une boîte de partout c'est à
dire que tu sais moi je fais de 0,1
alors il faut que je me lève tôt j'ai
fait de france info je lise la presse
que j'écrivais mes conneries que j'aille
tourner enfin c'est le dernier que j'ai
vus travailler comme ça sa perruque qui
est fait gaffe annonce vient pas je vais
me coucher bah je vais me coucher je
viens et un apport une heure mais
attends toi ça te fait un bon sujet mais
je suis un sujet à part entière c'est
quoi ça c'est encore un dépôt de ça
alors c'est pour toi
non c'est vrai alors ouais il n'a pas
préparé ces questions et il prend des
appels chez moi ouais c'est ce qu'on
appelle se [__] de la gueule du monde
car il vient oui il arrive il s'habille
bien je suis en cuir en dessous et il
est encore en dessous on aura tout de
suite un bon état temps c'est un ami de
la boîte bas bien un moment je suis en
france et pourquoi je suis crevé je suis
crevé à temps gg faits michèle cotta
attaché été dans les bois j'ai ramassé
un crapaud qu'on a mis dans un truc avec
les enfants tu vas voir le lui fait pas
peur parce que c'est car n'a rien tapé
il est l'artisan un diplôme il est là là
on a mis dans le bocal avec les enfants
on l'a appelé crapaud temps oui voilà
et donc je suis ramassé des insectes
glace défectueux voilà alors quand tu as
fait ça dans ta journée ça va puis à
temps car en retard je suis fatigué j'ai
pu 15 membres
non je viens pas
viens donc c'est pas je m'en fous ça
m'amuserait ménageait pas le temps que
tu veux faire maintenant je vais aller
coucher à je vais me coucher j'ai sur
l'équité parti je suis couché on s'en va
non moi je vais je passer de chercher
pour l'emmener dans cette voie de
partout c'est ce que je vais faire dans
la botte de partouzes un tu as regardé
comme tout le monde
et regardez quad et c'est pitoyable ça
va être un pot pour nos dix années 60
les greluches parcours avec bilou avait
fixé dorcel mag la paix vient en plus
ils permettent ce genre de boîte et
c'est à perpète c'est déjà peut-être
trouvé des stars aux marques va sûrement
ça suffit c'est ca les toilettes à côté
de l'étoile un saut de l'amour je te
jure excuse moi je me compte envoyer les
regarde ailleurs latine et l'asie mais
tout ça ça vient de ton club tu vas
sympa d'entendre bon tu viens pas en
avant pour la 47e fois je ne viens pas
me coucher gentil monsieur redisk
sainte-thérèse center a pas de connexion
de ça à ma vache mendiants front c'est
très beau par exemple jean paul ii il
est l'âme ne voit pas bien aller
chercher en dessous de nature pas ça
fait pour que la m va takkal
là tu verras jean brottes moi je les
trouvais gens je crois à madère bonsoir
bonne soirée dans la boîte on tend vers
une cassette
tu crois que tu vas avoir la force à moi
je regarde toi tu regardes l'étude
plastique un petit peu non non et non
pas ça du film ainsi la femme d un sou
le corps des autres à des soupirs de
volupté on s'en fait quand c'est pas la
nôtre mais c'est que d'autres
d'abord on se dit vous et puis on se dit
tout on s'envoie inverse on s'envoie en
l'air et tout là-haut tout là-haut on
regarde en bas et qu'est ce qu'on y voit
la femme d un sou corps des autres au
soir ça vous venez faire la fête ou non
je veux voir vous videz les couilles
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que tu jamais vu du bon
thierry je te présente ma femme on voit
mon soit retirée elle appelle tous
coiffés ouais c'est obligatoire
j'aimerais bien coup moi ici les
quartiers où il veut pas venu en tout
cas les 15 0 je connais pas non pas le
mec de piana lequel
elle est l'une des rejets meeddat et les
vraies mais tu as raison moi non plus
parce que je m'ennuyais hamel
un truc minyana les salles aux abords
des [__]
je peins jean quoi tu vois un truc forte
non non non c'est vrai que c'est votre
mari s'est mariée il ya non alors ça se
passe bien
ouais l'un dans l'autre ça va ouais tu
vois toi là-bas aussi
c'est quand même temps que dirige les
boîtes je suis plus de 18 ans avant je
fais 18 ans mais avant que tu faisais
quoi avant ben alors je trouve dans
l'ordre
bâle est un des pilotes de chasse jean
et antiquaires n'arrivant plus à deux
phases plus qu'on commande l'armée
française ouais je suis rentré à 14 ans
à 14 ans voir mais ouais et puis je suis
resté jusqu'à 25 en 26 mois et s'il veut
du pilote de chasse mercenaires un peu
au fond ou avec d'autres denard après
ben sûr arrivé à paris après un grave
accident et à ta santé
merci et pisa j'ai simplement été beau
canter j'ai fait l'école du loup ouais
après j'ai quitté l'école du louvre
j'ai vécu deux ans et des grandes
comédiennes dont je tairai le nom ou et
puis après ben j'ai une usine de tricot
et depuis 18 ans le chien des boîtes je
n'ai que 56 ans d'adolescents ouais mais
comment tu as le droit tient une boîte
comme ça à paris cette alliance a
maintenant c'est tous les ans 85
j'étais pas toléré avant 84 ha bon voilà
c'est à dire que les homosexuels russes
a fait la veille droite de sulu de ce
sceau d'eau miser mais nous on n'avait
pas le droit de rêver se sont brisés de
saint louis
ce dôme isère entre autres mais les et
des couples hétéros mariés n'avaient pas
le droit de ceux de cessange mrc et a eu
des problèmes en cas de problème grave
j'étais en prison
la banque pour avoir une boîte comme ça
pour avoir une boîte comme ça mais
c'était normal on l'était après neuf
mois et demi et après je me conter des
histoires dans les petites essaieront de
la sodomie apprennent à non j'ai pas
essayé moi j'ai perdu complètement leurs
goûts sexuels en arrivera vraiment dans
sa tasse entre irina combien de boîtes
comme ça va
attaquants et cissé a plutôt l'air quand
même prochain basique campagne
ah ouais parce que avant avant de tenir
des boîtes
j'ai suivi la plus grande école de
sexologie de france qui est où j'étais
diplômés d'ailleurs c'est l'université
du bois de boulogne
ouais où j'étais agrégé de sexologie au
bois de boulogne tous les soirs en
attendant les vous pas avec l'exigence
branlant et en organisant plane soir
chez azal le début le début de la grande
époque des années 67 68 ouais voilà à
l'époque j'étais brocanteurs et
organiser des soirées échangistes
ouais même au père lachaise on a fait
des soirées entre amis
voilà dans les caves où le gardien du
père lachaise a touché une fortune à
m'aimer mais très bien c'était quoi
avant ici ça a été la demeure de
de jean cocteau et jean marais c'était
le regarde saunière a précédé vadim
après ça a été une association de golf
dans les grandes soirées ici à commerce
ont besoin 200 personnes
arrêt 6b ensemble a baissé c'est pas le
temps les choses l'amour 1 c'est mieux
parce que je vois pas ici des gens veut
dire que pour baiser un son pas primaire
les gens qui voudraient quand même ils
ont un esprit on les adore les jeux
n'est déposé choqué a jamais jamais été
choqué dans ma vie tu sais pourquoi j'ai
jamais été choqués parce que la première
fois que j'ai fait l'amour dans ma vie
ça l'écran l'oncle et ma tante et
j'avais 13 ans avant et maintenant est
maintenant de 6 jeux lassus c'est bien a
eu le droit à un bon dessert aussi la
sucer mal elle m'invitait une copine à
elle qui avait 60 ans et j'étais obligée
de l'alléger j'avais trouvé 13 ans mais
à partir de là je te dire une chose
quand mes parents me demander où tu veux
passer des vacances je disais toujours
chez tata joseph parce que j'ai passé
les vacances les plus merveilleuses à
partir de ce jour là plus rien a évoqué
dans ma vie comme on seront serait ici
il faut être accompagné ce soir à part
l'après-midi ou en art ont accepté
célibataire parce que l'après midi ses
découpes un peu c est moi qui ai dansé
après midi dans paris c'est à dire que
les après midi ses découpes qui vient de
marier et dont les hommes adorent voir
ma femme faire l'amour avec 5,6 m haies
on la regarde regarde leur femme et se
vend alors donc on axe appelé des cinq
six mecs les 5-6 mec donc les
célibataires d'après midi mais moi aussi
je suis comme un pour dire ça mais je
voudrais te dire une chose j'ai fait des
cours à la sorbonne ne l'était en tant
que intervenants la sorbonne
on m'a posé cette question on m'a dit
vous êtes impuissant parce que vous
voyez votre femme faire l'amour avec
d'autres pas du tout j'ai 56 ans j'ai
jamais fait l'amour dans ma vie avec ni
un travesti ni avec la protection elle
n'y a qu'un autre mais par contre quand
je vois ma femme se fait reprendre
nouveau -1 à ce moment là je fais un
transfert mme de mon homosexualité et 20
à 30% que j'ai en moi de ma féminité
tout le monde
comme tout le monde et à ce moment là je
deviendrai jamais ma femme et sa mexico
c'est ça l'histoire c'est assez simple
il faut pour pouvoir la disputer
oui et nous parents tu la vois jouer à
mort avec un tenant à eux alors au
contraire et moi je lui demande de se
donner bien un homme de l'embrasser sur
la bouche
parce que ce qui m'excite le plus vieux
c'est pas qu'elle se donne un qu'elle
fuit ce avec un mec comme on sait
qu'après leur une fois que tout est
terminé
elles reviennent à 2 s'assied sur mes
genoux et qu'elle ment pas et ça ça
m'excite beaucoup parce que ce qui
m'excite le plus c'est que pendant un
quart d'heure vingt minutes c'est thomas
eu l'impression qu'ils pouvaient
posséder ma femme
en fin de compte ces détergents 5 oui
d'accord donc c'est un super sentiment
de possession est maintenant je suis
très cérébral
on s'accroche à ça parce que même les
gens qui viennent après easy prennent
goût non j'imagine que un couple qui est
venu chez toi deux trois week-ends nous
suivent
oui après s'ils ne peuvent pas
s'empêcher droite est là parce que je
perdais chez eux
c'est le seul a vu que je peux te faire
ce soir mais je le dis à toi ouais pour
une femme pour un coût c'est pire qu'une
pure de mots de mon film bah ouais ou la
première ligne que des individus vont
prendre de leur vie et peuvent plus en
principe un espace compris quand ils
sont chez eux et ce en mer voilà mais il
se passe le film de leur soirée ouais on
ce qui m'excite le plus avec ma femme
c'est devant les gens qui sont brûlés
dont la clé n'a montré non plus tout ça
et à partir de là tout le ce quand je
suis dans le lit avec elle pour le film
la soirée me repasse et d'ailleurs je
lui interdis de mettre une culotte quand
elle descendra dans ce club je veux que
les sont derrière à la disponibilité dès
demain et apprennent me raconta vitus et
pour copains qui se dit on a mis tout ça
il m'a mis la main aux fesses çà çà çà
çà mexique cette amitié et wassa d'accès
qu'est ce qu'elle est joli nom des
femmes pour trouver tous les deux vous
faites l'amour tous les deux n'ont
savouré en même temps vous avez pu fait
l'amour que tous les deux ans après midi
on la fait tous les atouts les deux web
serait promis de leur nez dans un bordel
à bordères
[Rires]
je préfère verte
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu